so was geht hier zur max und herzlich
willkommen zum heutigen video wir
spielen minecraft 1.9 pvp zusammen mit -
tut was wir sehen wir erst mal antesten
numero uno und dienen uns damit was da
drin manche von euch ist es bestimmt
schon die meistens wissen minecraft 1.9
ist vor allem pvp update kann man sagen
auch komplett update genannt wenn man
hier mit dem schwert schlägt merkt man
schon es hat ein delays heißt man
schlägt langsamer als sonst das erste
was man in der 1.9 kann beginnen das
heißt man brüsten die version kann
gratis daraus also ist frisch kam heute
raus ich checke gar nicht ich habe die
angst echter kraftvoll verpacke ich bin
auch sehr gespannt
ich glaube es gibt ganz neu das macht
echt minecraft vp ganz neu ist hab ich
mal also thema taktik sondern mit dem
schlagen aber ich weiß auch nicht genau
wie es geht also ob man da einfach jetzt
ewig warten musste sich das entgehen
reloaded oder ob man einfach auf
steinhöfels gespannt wer gewinnt jetzt
noch kerzen kann jemals bayern das ist
ein paar mehr
ich habe fünf regeneriert du auch so
ultraschnell ja vergleichsweise doch
relativ schnell ultraschall also
wirklich schneller als 50
wie viele hatten noch 66
das heißt der erste test habe schon
gesehen dass dort alles ein bisschen
langsamer wenn man so mit dem schwert
schlägt lasst uns doch einfach mal an
die zweite kiste gehen und dass darin
die nächste neuerung rausholen das
schild leute und ich muss sagen das
finde ich echt extrem nah ist meine grip
das schild dann steht man so da von
außen kann blocken man kann schlagen und
ich finde das schild das ist macht pvp
in der 19 deutlich interessanter ich war
mit einer von denen die am anfang so
groß aufgeschrieben so l19 pvp wird
minecraft voll kaputt machen wir haben
damit unsere einmal geschlagen also
immer gekämpft
ich muss sagen das ist richtig richtig
cool ich würde aus anfangs geht zurück
in deine bock 321 war das wird das wird
so spannend
ich habe schon richtig die ahnung von
taktik
okay ich mache die kasse taktik ich mach
dir gar kein schaden und hörst diese
komischen 11 nicht locken keine hürde
dar schlägst klopft schild wird mein
ding
doch mama hast du kein schaden bekommt
ich meine wenn man sozusagen beschämt
blog habe ich ein halbes jahr schaden
oder so aber die eine sobald das ding
raus ist so könnte es aussehen das man
einfach so da steht und wartet und ich
will doch nur dass brot essen leute das
machen
das macht wirklich spaß ich war das
richtig es ist so minecraft lich neu ich
bin immer mein kampf bhp und jetzt
plötzlich in ihm zusteht ist das krass
das ist richtig cool vorweist etwas
krass lehrerin war mit dem mit dem neuen
update kommt ja es ist wurde auch extra
bei war ob die 19 gewartet und dann muss
es doch nicht gemacht weil es schwer ist
nummer zwei geht an mich vielleicht
nicht ganz fair begeht man mich kiste
nummer drei hat auch etwas extrem cooles
drin und zwar den neuen bogen den alten
bogen besser gesagt mit den neuen teilen
der erste fall den wir hier am start an
ist der spektral viel einsatz niemand
nehme das schild unter fans und zwar
dieser fall keine ahnung warum aber
genau das macht er da der macht willen
um den gegnerischen spieler um diese
verrückten ja licht animation sieht aus
wie super secret service irgendwie und
ich glaube der sache dass man seinen
gegner auch wenn es dunkel ist sehen
kann dass man auch in der dunkel in der
dunkelheit seine gegner sieht ist auf
jeden fall voll crazy ich glaube das hat
jetzt fürs pvp keinen großen weiteren
vorteil
aber ich kann ich schon sagen es geht
jede menge anderer pvp pfeile und die
wir natürlich auf der reihe nach noch
austesten
ok warte mal solche abschießen oder ist
direkt hatte professor becker ist jetzt
hätte
ich bin so großen nachteilen pvp max
richtig geil mit dem blocken wohnt
einsammeln beim essen
die haben sich echt gedanken macht ob
das gefühl damit wird alles ca
ausbalanciert was von von minecraft
spielern bisher kritisiert wurde
du kannst jetzt mit einem bogen einfach
nicht mehr so krass wenn der anderen
schild hat kannst aber nicht mehr so
krass regelmäßig den anderen rasieren
und mit dem schwert kann ist der ping
nicht mehr so eine große wichtigkeit
also insgesamt für die allgemeinheit die
pvp spiel bleiben die echten gutes
update nächste kiste in der nichts drin
ist kann ich nicht drin ist alles drin
man ist mittendrin
bei der 34 hierbei denn vieles was drin
wir ihn noch davon
leute ich war gerade dumm und wir sagen
wir schauen uns auch die nächste kiste
an zwar die letzte die vierte kiste aber
ich denke jetzt ist schon gleich vorbei
nein das ist nicht wir gucken einfach
mal rein so sieht das nämlich aus im
prinzip kann man sagen dass die pfeile
so ziemlich alle wirkungen von den
zauber trinken haben sprungkraft yen
schwäche schwäche glück also es gibt
alle pfeile in allen außer grundig es
gibt glück genau das ist alles neu ich
finde auch gerade das macht es wieder
deutlich deutlich interessanter auch für
für ware unter anderem bei wenn man
jetzt zum beispiel team battles hast
dann verwalter verwenden halt einfach
die die pfeile mit den positiven
effekten auf die kollegen wenn man
allerdings irgendwie keine ahnung
gegen op-team kempf oder sowas dann
schießt man die andere einfach auf
distanz zum beispiel selbst sprungkraft
abschließen wenn man trifft kann man das
denn und das schmeckt ja du hast auch
noch getroffen
ich habe jetzt die schlechte drin
nein ich muss doch meine pfeile benutzen
ich war bis drei der langsamkeit jaja
das session 23 ich hatte gerade ein
inventar genommen du kleine sheeta du
ich gebe einfach alles jetzt ist gerade
alles drin
ach so was sollte ich vielleicht sei
daneben komme ich nicht an ich habe
keine hoffnung mit was ich fragen gerade
abgeschlossen habe
ach so weiß welche die ganze feier
reingepumpt habe tja leute also ich
finde auf jeden fall minecraft apps so
wie es jetzt ist
wie es mit der 19 jetzt geworden ist
echt echt interessant ich bin sehr
gespannt was die ganzen server damit
machen und wie das bei der community
ankommt ich freue mich ehrlich gesagt
darauf damit um zu experimentieren wird
sagen wir machen noch ein finales fälle
so leute es beginnt jetzt das wette das
finale battle wir haben wir haben eine
volle diamant rüstung und und den ein
oder anderen ice geblockt den ein oder
anderen verdammt als linke lankas jetzt
ich trinke nicht ich dachte was mir im
blickfeld gerückt nenne ich hab die
sonne hat den schadensfall eingetreten
ist hab ich da und lenkt von einig
der erste davon wir haben wow
okay das sind op schadensfall und du
verschießt alle brand
august vor leute das wird richtig
spannend also wenn man so hinter das
schwert trifft dann als passionierter
diese also hinter richtig von hinten
schlagen dann ist es irgendwie dann
bringt es auch nichts mehr
hier auch komplett biologisch neben ok
man kann immer noch kommt aber es machte
kaum schaden müsste wissen dass wir
gerade warten
irgendwie weil wir weil wir durch sind
oder so was macht kaum schaden wenn du
ein combo
wie sieht es bei dir mit herz ich bin
noch recht gut dabei seien 18 herzen ich
bin auch gut dabei sind schon relativ
kleiner arsch als sehr ehrenhaft
dafür bringe ich mich direkt nochmal um
hilfe
das finde ich wenn ich super danke
schnaps verdient damit will ich sagen
leute das war's vom pvp 19 wette ich
hoffe es hat euch gefallen ich will mich
sehr freuen wenn ihr leid da das tat
auch bei franz vorbei und bald wieder
lakic und von uns beiden okay dann bis
dahin macht und viel